[Music]
violence in Chicago out of control last
weekend 74 people were shot across the
city 12 of them were killed president
Trump's expressed deep concern over the
escalating violence but rahm emanuel the
city's ultra liberal mayor told him to
butt out you recently declared chicago
schools a trump free zone the city of
chicago yeah the whole thing whole thing
I didn't I don't know if I've ever
thought this but I did yesterday and you
actually take away a president security
clearance ROM someone's got to control
your city it's totally out of control
almost 4,000 people have been murdered
in Chicago since you took office look at
those statistics here with reaction
diamond and silk all right ladies what
do you think about ROM and the just
massive amount of violence going on
there you know first of all let me just
say this here I think that the president
should send in the feds because you
can't have this level of violence tests
turf wars and drugs flowing through that
city without somebody being paid a
kickback paddywhack give a dog a bone to
turn a blind eye so the first thing he
should do is send in the fans and then
send in the National Guard to clean up
that place you know I think it's so sad
that we have black on black crime people
getting crossing the cross fires of
bullets and and being killed for no
reason innocent innocent blood and where
is the L Sharpton's to Jesse Jackson
being double acp and the NFL player in
NFL players should kneel and talk to our
brother there are black brothers and
tell them to stop killing each other and
where they at they're nowhere to be
found
but if this was so what this is happen
the white people know here come
everybody going against Korn to the
situation to see how we can solve it it
is time for us to pay attention to
what's going on what's going on this is
a black on black crime this is our black
man killing other black men and innocent
people get any crosses across fires and
it needs to stop and this is also a
clear example of what Democrat ran
cities look like you have individuals
like this particular mayor that will
prefer to fund sanctuary cities instead
of fun individuals to help clean up the
city
national disgrace and the mainstream
media is not even holding Rahm Emanuel
accountable a lot of other news stories
this past week and last couple weeks
the media has just completely buried so
the other day the president goes down to
Florida and announces a massive increase
in jobs as a result of his policies down
there we also saw the remains of the
Korean War soldiers returned and look at
this here pence comes out to receive the
remains in a very somber and important
and historical ceremony and look at the
network's ABC News didn't even give it
30 seconds CBS didn't cover it NBC
Nightly News didn't cover it MSNBC
didn't take it live I mean it's just
completely ridiculous the way that
they're burying these types of stories
and then you had another really poignant
moment where the president stops his
motorcade after one of his events and
gets out and starts greeting
firefighters and shaking their hands it
was just one of those really touching
presidential moments that the media if
it had been Barack Obama would have
picked up and led with on the nightly
news but if it's this president
they don't even cover it at all you know
unlike other people that probably didn't
vote for the president we voted for this
man because of this reason we know it's
hard he loves people and that should be
shown on national news because they
don't do that because they like to
disrespect him and disparage him that's
the kind of narrative that they like to
run on this president instead of giving
him praise for the good things that he's
doing he's doing things that we've never
seen done in our country be more but
they don't want to give him the credit
for that what they want to do is say on
their own stinking thinking narrative
and that's why we ignored them we we
really appreciate this president for
everything that he is doing for this
country and that's why I tell you when
you bet on Trump when you vote for Trump
you never can go wrong with that
president so so much that we wish he
could be the president forever yeah you
have to change the Constitution for that
one okay
so Rosie O'Donnell doesn't want them to
be President forever once an impeached
immediately she did a round of media
interviews here she is on a cable
network
I believe that Trump is loathed in
America that people are embarrassed and
ashamed of who he is and that come
election day we're going to stand up at
the polls and let him know and unless he
goes in and has the Russians kind of fix
it like he did last time in 2016 you
know we're gonna see him gone ladies
what do you think about Rosie O'Donnell
making a comeback Rosie don't realize
that the American people also feel
dislike and disdain for her too that's
right maybe she should do what she told
everybody she was gonna do is go instead
of her singing in front of the White
House what she should have been doing
was sitting in that jailhouse violations
of giving too much campaign contribution
so all of these people on the alias
names that's right I forgot about that I
forgot about that yeah I don't think I
remembered it uh yeah you know what you
have a better memory than I do and I I
don't think the feds uh are probably
gonna make her a priority all right I'll
see you guys next week